MALE SPEAKER:
Without further ado,
I am thrilled to introduce
Jean Baptiste Huynh who
is one of the people
who's out there working
in the educational game space,
who are building games that
actually look like games.
And we've been talking about
the space with some colleagues
for quite some time that we need
more games that look like this.
If we're going to push change
and educational achievement,
we need games that
actually feel like games,
and Jean has created some
very graceful games for us
and he's going to give us an
introduction to them today.
Thank you.
Please welcome Jean Baptiste.
JEAN BAPTISTE HUYNH: Thank you.
MALE SPEAKER: Thank you.
JEAN BAPTISTE HUYNH:
I don't know if it's
me who found this title.
I guess not.
Maybe it's you.
Redesigning the math experience,
lessons from Dragonbox.
So redesigning the math
experience-- that's the title.
Why do we want to do that?
And I need to start with that
because my son, one of my sons,
14 years old, last time he
came, it was in the kitchen,
and he said, daddy, why
are you doing what you do?
When you get that kind of
question from your son,
you have to think twice,
maybe three times.
I'm working really hard
to make this happen.
And I said, well, my son,
why do they do that, yeah?
I guess I want all kids to learn
math more rapidly, much faster.
And he posed, and he
looked at me and said,
it's a job for nothing.
Because if you're successful
and kids can learn faster math,
the game of school
will change anyway
so that the requirements
for kids-- you see my point?
They will be higher.
There will always be
inflation about what
we require for kids went to
enter the best universities.
But then the question
is will the universities
as we know them today change.
This I don't know.
But I had to think twice really.
But I can not but design the
games and the experiences
that I'm making.
So I'm going to
keep on doing that,
although my kid is
really skeptical,
which is a bit weird.
I guess maybe he wants
me to be home more.
So basically, yeah,
it's a beautiful picture
I received from a foundation.
They are using one of our
games in South Africa.
I do the games also to
get this, more of this.
I was a teacher for
a couple of years.
Before that, I was
working in finance
as a stock portfolio manager.
As a teacher, it's very seldom,
especially in high school,
that kind of yes, natural
way to say I mastered that.
It was a little bit
difficult, but I got it.
And then maybe you
experience that kind
of feeling from time to time
in your work-- a difficult task
and then, yes!
And basically that's
what I want kids
to get as a feeling every
day, basically, when
they start learning something.
It should be yes,
I can manage that.
And they are empowered
by what they've learned.
This is the big motivation.
So I have spent the
last eight years
of my life trying to increase
the productivity of math
teaching.
And from teaching, I'm
more into learning now
because the role
of the teacher is
changing in my head at least.
So let's say we want to
redesign the way we teach math
or learn math.
So what do we need to change?
So these are the
usual challenges
in a classroom-- problems of
motivation, difficult subjects,
meaning here we're
talking about pedagogy.
Even if you have a
kid really engaged
and you have a kid who really
wants to learn something,
sometimes it's really
hard to learn it.
And it's not because the
subject is really hard, I think.
On here it's very normative.
That's my view on the subject.
I think it's
because we have used
too little time to design a
way to communicate the subject
property.
So it's about pedagogy.
It's about representations.
And we'll come
back later to that.
The communication
barrier-- as a teacher,
like what I'm doing now,
I'm talking talking.
We talk too much in school,
and kids are not active enough.
And sometimes, you want
to communicate a big idea
and you don't have
the tools to do it.
And the language we use,
especially the oral language,
is pretty bad actually
because of the short memory
and other stuff that I know,
but I have the intuition
that it's not effective at all.
The more you talk,
the less people
understand usually,
in a classroom.
You have time constraints
in a classroom,
and you have one teacher
usually and 30 kids.
And you're a big loser.
You want to
communicate something,
it's really not good at
all, especially in math.
Maybe I did not mention
something very important.
It's the fact that usually when
we learn, we need feedback.
In the classroom there's
very little feedback.
You can make the calculation
that if you spend two minutes
to give feedback to
a student, you're
going to spend your
time doing feedback
and never teach
anything actually.
If we want to change
things as well,
I think it's important
to understand
the difference between learning,
practice, and assessment.
Especially in my work, people
don't know the difference.
When they buy an education
app or a solution,
they are served with a
quiz, an adaptive quiz
maybe, but still a quiz.
You can learn from a
quiz maybe a little bit.
You might be motivated by it.
But there is no real
learning component in it.
So the assessment industry
is a billion dollar industry,
the practice
industry maybe less,
and learning industry
really per se, today,
that's teachers,
books, and tutoring.
We don't have any tools
really to learn or teach
better, that are really
designed from a very
sound pedagogical viewpoint.
So I wanted really
to make a point here.
Learning is not done
by anyone almost.
It might be provoking.
You might consider I'm crazy.
But my experience
is that nobody's
doing research and
development in this field,
and it's a pity in
a knowledge society.
It's a little bit weird,
actually-- very weird.
So how can we change that?
So we know the challenges.
And the only way
we can change that
is really to understand
how kids get motivated
and how they learn.
How do we do that?
And I guess there's
only one way to do it.
You have to put yourself
at the same level as kids.
You have to listen
to your customers.
And already there are many
teachers who understand this.
Usually, teachers don't
have the time to observe.
They don't have the
time to reflect.
And they don't have the means
to act upon the reflection they
might have.
OK?
So the process to change things,
it takes time and energy.
But that's the only
solution if you
want to change this
educational landscape
and get really good tools.
So when I was a teacher,
I tried many things.
I had actually a partner
and we designed a couple
of solutions, IT solutions.
I tested many, many solutions.
At the beginning, it was
pretty teacher-centered.
I needed tools, administrative
tools, to gain time.
But at the end of
the day, really,
it was very clear that a
big part of the solutions
are video games, or they
were video games at the time.
It was really very
simple, very clear.
So why?
I don't say it's
the only solution.
It's just part of the solution
and we have not invested enough
in this solution.
So why it might
work and why I do
believe we can
change dramatically
the effectiveness of teaching
and learning mathematics?
Well, through games
you can create
a context that motivates kids.
It's about the context.
Some kids are motivated by
the context of school, grades.
And it works.
It's OK.
Social context might work.
There are many ways to get
motivated to do well in school
and to learn.
The beauty with video games is
that you can create something
really out of the
blue almost that
is going to motivate
the majority of kids.
What I do love with video
games-- and I have to say,
I'm not a gamer myself.
It's just I'm a game
designer by accident.
It's because I want to
teach more effectively.
And therefore I need to
do what it takes to do it.
So I have to design
games, right?
In video games, you can
create digital manipulatives.
So what are manipulatives?
That's objects,
physical, generally,
that you can use in school
to manipulate stuff and get
an intuition, a
bodily intuition,
of what the concepts are.
In a video game, you can do
that in a digital version,
and you can add all
the feedbacks you want.
So if I would recommend
or give advice
to people who want to
get into this industry,
the first thing I
think you have to do
is create these
digital manipulatives.
And it's not only in
mathematics, actually.
I think it's for everything.
You want to manipulate stuff.
It's the most intuitive
way to learn stuff.
So it's very normative again.
I think we learned by metaphors.
At the beginning, it's
physical metaphors, and then
metaphors on metaphors.
But for the basic
learning stuff,
physical metaphors are
good, or digital metaphors.
Autonomy, you get that, of
course, in a video game.
You can advance
at your own pace.
Time on task high if you have
the subject in the game play.
And that's the reason why
it was very important to me
to create an experience
where whatever you do
is manipulating these digital
manipulatives, actually
math concepts.
So whatever you do,
as soon as you play,
you're actually playing
with math concepts.
So your time on task
is super, super high.
And in school, it's
super, super low.
And that is a reason
why I say we can really
change the efficacy of
teaching and learning.
And it's an
individual experience.
So much more effective when you
can experience stuff yourself
and create your
own understanding.
So when I realized that
video games were part
of the solution-- so it was
purely theoretical there,
right?-- I gathered a couple
of people I thought would be
interested in this mission
to create video games,
learning video games.
And we had a
brainstorming session.
And here are the
constraints I used.
So I've been a very influenced
by two people, Betty Edwards
and Tim Galloway.
Betty Edwards has
written this book.
She wrote this
book about drawing
on the right side of the brain.
And she divides the methodology
to learn to draw things
in, I think, a week.
And Tim Galloway
devised a solution
to teach anyone to play
tennis in 20 minutes.
So I discovered these two guys
on the page of the Research
Viewpoint Institute that
was created by Alan Kay.
And it resonated a
lot, what I've read.
They wrote two books, Betty
Edwards and Tim Galloway.
"The Inner Game
of Tennis," that's
the name of the book, the title
of the book of Tim Galloway.
And they had the same
problem as I had, actually.
Or I had the same
problem as they had.
The more they talked,
the less people
understood what they
wear meant to learn.
So they had to really
to question their roles.
And to some extent,
they understood
that they were a kind of barrier
between the subject they wanted
to teach and the
player or the learner.
And it felt exactly the same
with me with mathematics.
So the first very
important design principle
in all the games we're
making-- no words.
Eventually, it might
be a few words,
but at the very beginning, I
don't want to have any words.
I want to have a very
intuitive experience.
You can manipulation stuff.
You're going to
discover yourself
how it works, the
characteristics of the math
concepts.
And it's a very
difficult constraint.
but at the same time, it's a
constraint that when it works,
it works so beautifully.
No prerequisite--
that means that anyone
can play the game
you're going to design.
And something very,
very important,
the big ideas of mathematics.
I'm not interested in
teaching a small chunk
or bit of the curriculum.
I don't care about
the curriculum
when I design the games.
And it makes people crazy.
They say, ugh, you
cannot sell that.
And we don't sell that much.
That's true.
But I think that eventually
we will win this battle.
The more games that we
create, the more likely people
are to understand the power
of the tools we create, right?
So I used to give as an
example functions in math.
You start with a linear
function and then
second order functions, and
then polynomial function.
One year later, maybe a bit
of logarithmic function.
One year later, a little
bit of exponential function.
A little bit later, maybe a
combination of all of them
and so on.
It takes-- I don't
know-- five, six years
to see the different occurrences
of the type of functions,
the regular functions
that we use.
And functions, you know there's
an infinity of functions.
So how can you learn what a
function is with one occurrence
of a function?
It's impossible.
And still, we teach
it this way, right?
If I present a dog, you have
never seen a dog, and I say,
this is a dog.
Well, I don't know what a
dog is with one occurrence.
Maybe I see a cat and
I think it's a dog.
No, it's a cat.
What's the difference?
So I insist in my
team that I want
to teach the big ideas
so that kids can really
see the patterns.
And it does have an effect.
The power of teaching the big
ideas is extremely powerful.
It's really, really powerful.
Now we're designing a new game,
and we cover maybe five years
in just one game.
In two months-- I don't
know how much time
it will take to play it.
But it's really big differences.
And mathematics is really,
actually, not always,
but it's pretty consistent.
What's not consistent is the
language we use to teach it.
Now we have four
years experience
designing those kinds of games.
I'm amazed by the
lack of consistency
in the way we teach it
and the language we use.
Not only do we not use the
same symbols across the globe,
like the minus sign
might be the division
sign in some countries, a
minus sign in other countries.
And you think what?
Right?
The minus is both an
operation and it's also
the sign for negative numbers.
How do you distinguish the two?
So you have many problems of
design or in representation.
I'm French, and with numbers
we say quatre-vingt for 80.
Quatre-vingt is four by twenty.
And in English, the same.
You say eleven
instead of ten-one.
And it's small
details like that.
It makes the work to learn stuff
very complicated, unnecessarily
complicated.
Two hours.
Why two hours?
I don't know I just say we have
to go very quickly to the goal.
So two hours.
That's what we have.
That's a constraint.
One game, not many, many
activities and so on.
I want really an experience
with the digital manipulative,
the concept, and you're going to
learn through this experience.
So it should be one game
with math in the game play.
And it's very natural because
the only thing you do actually
in our games is to
manipulate math concepts
with another
representation, but still
math concepts with the
characteristics that are math.
So math should be
in the game play.
So we designed these
digital manipulatives,
and after a while, we see what's
the game with this concept?
Actually, with numbers for
example, what's the game there?
And actually, we discovered
a game with kids.
It's to create the
highest number.
This is a fantastic
game for kids.
They want to go forever,
towards eternity maybe,
or infinity at least.
It's beautiful.
So I'm going to go through
the three games we have made,
or are making, and
highlight some learnings.
So the first thing
is representations.
I mentioned that
problem of language.
This is the prototype on paper.
All the games are prototyped
paper and tested on paper.
It goes much, much, much, much
faster-- really, really fast.
Some people say, well, no.
It takes me no
time to develop it.
I can program it.
No, no.
Forget about it.
You cannot iterate on that.
I take a piece of paper.
I cut and so on.
I test.
In three hours, I'm done.
I have a first iteration, right?
So this problem
of representation
is really, really key.
If you want to learn
something faster,
I think you have to work
with the representations.
Not only in mathematics.
It can be other subjects.
A key challenge-- now I'm
thinking of marketing.
Not only marketing, but
actually disseminating
the value of your work.
It's that if you change
the representation of math,
the majority of
people will never
understand what you're doing.
And when I to say the
majority, it's 99.999%.
So it's a challenge.
It's bit too innovative maybe.
For kids, it doesn't
play any role.
Because they learn math
with this representation,
and it's math.
Once you have understood the
concept the underlying concept,
then to change
the representation
doesn't cause any
problem for kids.
On the contrary, adults, if
you show a new representation
for something they know,
they are really disturbed.
So some people ask me how did
you get the idea for this game?
Well, it started with
a simple challenge.
It was to get my son to
understand negative numbers.
That's negative numbers, the
kind of symmetry you have.
And I wanted to show it to
him in a very elegant way.
And certainly it exists.
I don't know.
I put it a card, and I
put a number on one face,
and on the other face
I put minus 1, so 1
minus 1, 2 minus
2-- very simple.
It's really logic, actually.
And little by little, I
cannot explain what happened,
something happened in my brain.
And I was thinking, wow, we
could do that with everything,
and maybe with algebra.
We could design this
game with cards.
Oh yeah.
Well, let's do it.
And then I cut a lot of
paper and tested the game.
I had no experience
really with testing games.
I am not a game designer, right?
But I saw my kids, they were
getting the rules very quickly.
So I was thinking,
wow, it's working?
And I was thinking, wow,
it's working really fast!
So then I was
thinking, well, let's
make a game about that, right?
It was after the
brainstorming session
I had with my now colleagues.
What does it take to go from
this prototype to do this?
Well, a year, 10 hours a day.
The last month, 20 hours a day.
Doesn't seem too complicated,
but it was really challenging.
So we started with
this representation.
So I wanted really kids to
get a very intuitive way
to perceive what equations
are with a simple rule
or simple game goal.
Isolate the unknown, right,
for linear equations.
And I don't pay attention
to the curriculum, right?
But I don't pay attention to
the formalism of mathematics
either.
So I can really
innovate as I want.
So I said, well, one
line's so boring.
Let's put that in
two dimensions.
And then a colleague of
mine said, oh, we should
do that in three dimensions.
So we could do that too.
I put the cards, and it was OK.
It worked pretty well.
And then we were thinking,
yeah, but this is equation
solving in two dimensions.
We've no operators,
no signs as usual.
We were pretty satisfied by
that because it was a real game.
When we playtested it,
it was working really
fantastic-- extremely powerful.
So powerful that at
the birthday of my son,
he was nine at the time, I
put a tablet on the table.
Kids were playing poker.
So I said can you please
playtest this for me?
And they said, well OK.
And at the end of the birthday,
they were not playing poker.
They were around the table
playing this game in this form
together, social process.
But it was a fantastic
experience for me.
But it was not enough.
Because if I show that either to
teachers or parents or whoever,
they don't see anything.
They don't see it's equations.
They think well, nice
game, Jean Baptiste.
It's not math.
I was thinking deep down
inside, but this is not math.
It's just another
representation,
but it's equation solving.
So we had to scratch
our heads many times
and go, well, shall we go
to the normal formalism?
We didn't know we could do
that, actually, at the time.
So it took us really
a lot not of energy
but a lot of-- what would
be the word for that?
It's counter intuitive for
me to go in that direction.
I was pretty satisfied
with this one.
And a lot of effort, mental
efforts, to say well,
we're going there.
And I was thinking, it's
going to get boring.
So we introduced equal and plus.
And it didn't make any
difference to kids.
So it was just a
lot of learning.
Wow, really?
The representation
doesn't matter to kids
once they have
understood the concept.
And then we were
thinking, well, shall
we dare put some letters
just to see what's going on?
And to kids, it
just doesn't matter.
It's the same game.
And the beauty-- I don't
know if you see here.
In the equation,
you see a box there.
The box at the top left,
that's the unknown.
And there are some glow
or some stars around it.
It's kind of a
meta-concept, right?
That's the unknown.
We changed that to the x.
And many parents came to us.
They had playtested that
themselves as adults.
And they were complaining.
They thought that our design
was really, really bad,
that we were doing a bad job.
It's never going to work.
Kids would never understand
that the box there and the x,
it's the same object.
Many, many-- and they
were furious at us,
angry, pretty red
reaction sometimes.
It's never going to work.
I would never use that.
It's never going to-- And
kids, how long does it
take for them to understand
that the box and the x
is the same thing?
I can tell you-- a millisecond.
A question, where is the box?
Oh, it's there.
Case closed.
So we had a first
version of the game.
It took a year to do with
very simple linear equation.
And it took us a year
again to do a new game
with much more learning.
And then we put parentheses.
So we found a
metaphor of bubbles.
We added negative numbers,
so you can flip everything.
Fractions.
And you can create your
own variable or parameter
with this box there.
It's extremely powerful.
You will need that for
integrals and so on.
And it worked pretty well.
But it's a little
bit too much maybe.
It takes six hours
to perform the game.
So not all kids are
motivated to go to the end.
And it's not a problem.
I mean, you cannot get all
the kids, all the time.
Even a normal game
would not achieve that.
So for us, it's a tool.
We are making tools, right?
So I guess with this
first game, we really
understood the power
of representations,
intermediate representations,
and how powerful the brain is.
As soon as you
understand patterns,
you can change a few
things, but you will still
recognize the patterns.
Maybe something else
I should add on that.
As a teacher, I used to spend
some time preparing my lessons.
And one day-- it's more
than a day actually--
I spent during a week,
20, 28 hours to prepare
a lesson of two hours.
28 hours for two hours.
No teacher is doing that, right?
I was doing that just
as an experiment.
And I got marginal better
results, only marginal.
That kind of game is made
by a multidisciplinary team
with game designers, art
directors, really experts,
28 years of experience.
So basically it's
four, five people
during a year
preparing this lesson.
It's not just a short
lesson, because there's
so much learning, right?
So what's going on there?
Yeah, that's the right
way to do it, I think.
New industry, new
tools, new productivity.
So after algebra.
We were wondering which
game we should make.
It was kind of
difficult, actually.
And at the end of the
day, we picked geometry,
and there were a lot of
fights within our team.
Because we had different goals.
If you don't know this book,
that's "Euclid's Elements."
It's a version by Oliver Byrne.
I had never actually
read "Euclid's Elements."
This is beautiful.
It's a beautiful book.
It's a piece of art.
Oliver Byrne, in the
late 19th century,
he was thinking, well, students
struggle to read this book.
Only written language,
small shapes and so on.
No colors-- nothing.
Really, really dry.
So he decided to create
a new representation
for angles and so on.
And it's beautiful.
And actually you can read
that, you can read proof,
prepositions, theorems, and so
on just like a novel almost.
And it's very satisfying
because it's very consistent.
There are flaws in "Euclid's
Elements," as you might know.
But still you perceive
the consistency
on the logic behind
mathematics, I
mean, with that kind
of geometry, right?
And the fight was
the beauty of this
and what I meant was very
important to kids, my kids,
in particular.
When you study
mathematics later on,
you really have to never
forget how you prove stuff.
That's the key element.
And I've been to elitist
schools in France and so on.
I mean, they do nothing to
teach you these basic elements--
nothing, zero.
On the contrary, I
wanted really to design
a game that teaches kids proof.
Not only proof, I wanted to
train the brains of our kids
to understand that you
can also use creativity
when you do proofs.
And if you are familiar
with "Euclid's Elements,"
the beauty is that you have
both a construction and proof.
Why is that?
Of course, if you
just draw stuff,
you never know if the
technique you used is correct.
Might be just random chance.
So you need to prove all the
construction methodologies
that you build.
And this is key.
We're running out of time
and money at this time.
And we had started with
the construction game.
And part of my team was saying,
well, let's release this game.
I say I will never
release this game.
Why?
Because we had some
levels that you
could, because of
the approximations,
reach a goal, that
you wanted build,
but it was not really the
truth, if truth exists.
And it was very obvious that
you wanted to get the proof,
to prove that what
you drew is correct
and you have really
reached this point.
And they were stressed.
We had a lot of back and forth.
And it's really demanding
to create a game.
And they say, well,
let's release the game.
And I say, no, we
don't release the game.
We don't have any
money, but still I
want to go towards proof.
So we met again.
We got proof but without
the creativity component.
If you remember
geometry, sometimes you
can draw a segment and
it appears a shape,
like a triangle or
something like that.
And then you can use that
to prove other stuff, based
on the properties of the
new shape you have drawn.
So we made this game.
And if you're
interested in marketing,
we call that "Dragonbox
Elements," because it was
about proof and not geometry.
And the majority of people
have never heard of elements,
so they didn't catch it
was about geometry proof.
But still called
"Dragonbox Elements."
I like it, but apparently people
are a bit confused by that.
We changed the representations
of, for example, a trapezoid.
That's the figure, the
shape, you see there,
this guy with two wings.
We had to find a
representation--
I will show you that on the
iPad-- of parallel lines.
Because remember, the
constraint is no language.
So we had to find a
new representation,
graphical representation,
for all the properties
of the shapes.
And it worked pretty
well, and kids love it.
And they see really the
consistency and the beauty
in proving stuff.
This is by far one of the
most important, I think,
games for mathematics that
you can give to your kid.
And you need to ask your
kids after playing this
what are you doing there?
Well, I want to
find this monster
but I'm missing some
information and evidence.
And you need to train that, not
only for mathematics but also
for writing.
It's a process.
You need to argue.
You need to build
your argumentation,
and you need to be trained.
And again, here, the
time on task is 100%.
Everything you do is proof.
So different
representations and so on.
Yeah.
So after we worked with
this geometry proof game,
we still had a bit of
money, and actually we
made some money on that energy.
And we were thinking,
what do we do now?
And we perceived that, where is
the limit between entertainment
and learning?
And I do know that some people
think that you shouldn't
create specific learning games.
And I agree.
I don't like the
expression learning games.
And I don't like the fact
that we target specifically
learning.
But at the same
time, mathematics
is, to me, at
least, just a game.
I'm not a game designer.
I just take the game of math,
and I reveal it in a game.
So I just work with the
representations, right?
But still I was
wondering is there really
a limit between entertainment
and that kind of learning?
And not only my intuition
but the playtests
tend to prove that
actually there is no limit.
There is no limit,
especially for younger ages.
Everything is just
play and games.
And if you take math,
it's just another game,
and it's very
consistent-- therefore,
it's an even better game.
So these days we're
working with numbers.
We have a very ambitious goal
to cover the full primary school
mathematics curriculum
with three games.
Other ways we test
things with prototypes
on paper and
different mechanisms
and to get a sense
of what the game is.
And after a while, we end
up with new representations
and new environments.
This is number one, number
two, number three, number four.
All of them are characters.
They have their
own personalities.
And they have properties that
are math properties, actually.
And kids just enjoy it.
Maybe what I want to mention
there to get the entertainment
value, it's not only
because of the graphics.
Of course, the game mechanics
are extremely important.
And the social
components are important.
But still, the fact that you
can get this graphic value
due to the fact that it's
appealing, it's important
and it has a huge
value, I think, to kids.
And then I say that there
are extremely no boundaries
between entertainment
and learning.
It's the same for kids, really.
And in the playtest, kids can
play that forever-- forever.
I've talked mainly about
games, but games are nothing.
It's just a resource, right?
And as a teacher and educator,
you cannot stop there.
What you're interested in is the
learning experience, not only
the design of games.
You're interested in
the full ecosystem.
What's going on?
How can your resources be used?
What kind of use
cases do you have?
And actually, what we are doing
now is putting a lot of energy
on how can we design the
learning experience, not only
the game?
So the social context
is extremely important.
This is a picture
from Norway, where
we organized a big competition.
Some 40 or 50,000
kids were registered.
Maybe 40,000 played during
a week, class against class,
highest number of equations
solved per student.
You would win an iPad
if your class wins.
Kids were playing at night.
40% of the time was
played outside the school
time, a beautiful experience.
Bigger scale, right?
A little anecdote--
so the competition
was be opened by the
prime minister in Norway,
where I'm based.
And at 8:15, I received
a call from a colleague.
Hello, Jean Baptiste.
I think we have a problem.
Many teachers are complaining.
The servers crashed.
I mean, you work at Google.
So you know what it means.
Something that we
had not foreseen
is the fact that
many teachers wanted
to participate in that
because the normal school
days are so boring.
And all of them had planned
to start playing at 8:00.
[LAUGHTER]
Beautiful anecdote.
I guess I lost two years
of my life stressing
like hell because the prime
minister would come and open
the ceremony.
We were in a classroom,
and kids were there.
I cannot connect.
And there was just journalists,
TV, press-- everyone was there
and that it was
really a nightmare.
And we did this project with
the University of Washington
with Zoran Popovitch,
Center for Game Science.
Nine hours difference, so
for them during the tonight.
So it was really a nightmare.
But they did a fantastic job.
We just lost 15,000 kids.
And I guess the
confidence and interest
from thousands of teachers.
They will never come
back to us, I guess.
I don't know.
And why do I say that?
Innovation is about
experimenting.
It's about failures as well.
And that's the learning process.
You cannot avoid it.
You can think a lot-- hard.
You're going to fail sometimes.
And what I perceive as very
difficult in the school system,
generally speaking, is
that you're not allowed
to fail many times, right?
So how to create a culture for
testing new stuff at a larger
scale?
Because sometimes a pilot is OK.
Usually pilots work.
Its when you have
the bigger scale
that things are really
getting exciting
and where you
discover new things.
So that was the
Algebra Challenge.
That's the name of the event.
We've run that in a couple
of states in the US.
We had that in Norway.
We're going to have
that in Uruguay soon.
Data, yeah.
So imagine you're a teacher.
You are teaching as usual.
You have prepared for
you lesson for one
to two hours, maybe
less, giving your lesson.
And when it's finished,
it's finished.
You don't know what happened.
You don't know how
kids have learned.
You don't know
what they learned.
You're going to know that when
you're going to give a test.
And the kids will know if
they have learned two weeks
after the test has been given.
So you have cycles of
something like a month
or a month and a half before
we know what's going on.
Usually with the
game of school we
know already what's going on.
Actually, it's not
necessary to play this game.
The good students are
still the good students.
Some accidents sometimes.
And the students who have lost
their self confidence, maybe
self esteem, they are losers.
They accept that.
And every month and a half,
they have a confirmation
that they are losers.
It's a beautiful game.
Not much data.
We know everything already.
But with the kind of tools we
have with these video games,
we have the opportunity
to collect data
about what kids are doing.
We can improve the algorithm to
serve adaptive levels to them.
So it's a big data
trend in education,
not based on quizzes
and assessment
but based on the
learning process.
Where are they?
What are they struggling with?
Which concept is difficult?
Which strategy are they using
to solve that type of equation
or that type of
geometry proof problem?
It's completing your work,
and it's not accessible
unless you have very good
game mechanics and good games.
And there's not
that many of them.
So I put that here because
creativity is not only
in mathematics.
It's also in editorial teams.
It only takes about 42
minutes to learn algebra
with video games.
What a beautiful title.
You can't imagine the
amount of hate it generated.
[LAUGHTER]
What?
This game is boo.
I didn't write this articles.
I'm sorry.
The only thing I'm doing is,
I'm doing a pretty good job
at designing games and
learning experiences,
and we're collecting data.
And I'm sorry if the
guy found this title.
Well, it generated a fair
amount of hate, really.
We had many people
who got awareness
about what we're doing.
And some people were thinking,
well, that's a good thing.
I want to try that.
Which is good.
But of course, we have
to take some perspective
and some distance with
the data we're getting.
Really, after one and half
hours, 95% of the kids,
after having played
one and a half hours,
are mastering the rules
of algebra in the game.
There is some help in
the game, but it's really
mathematical gameplay,
as I would call it.
So that means that they
are really learning.
So it's very efficient.
And the data we're collecting
are really, really,
really interesting for
understanding the learning
process.
And it's real learning.
Although it's not transferred
to pencil and paper,
we can do that later.
And we have made many stuff to
be able to ease this process.
Yeah, so I want to
say we are humble
and we are really into learning.
We are not interested in those
kinds of titles or headlines
although it gives
some publicity.
These are some of
statistics we got
from the different
challenges we have performed.
And I want to attract your
attention to the two lines
here-- 10 times faster
and 7 more content.
10 times faster, that's the
difference between the slowest
learners and the fastest
learners in this [INAUDIBLE].
10 times.
So as a teacher, you
know that there are
big differences between kids.
But now we can measure
that with adaptive levels,
with math in the game mechanics,
time on task, and so on.
10 times.
If you think of
that, you say why
are these kids in
the same classroom?
It doesn't work like that.
I mean, there is a problem,
fundamental problem, there.
And not only that, we know
the number of exercises
we have to give to kids.
And between the slowest
and the fastest,
seven more content,
seven more content
we have to deliver
to the slowest kids.
So we can put a number on this.
And it's not one.
It's not 0.5.
It's 7 and 10 times.
It's really big numbers.
What do we do with that?
How can you engage a motivate
a kid to work 10 times
more than another one?
How can you do that?
How can a school do that?
How can a teacher do that?
It's impossible--
mission Impossible.
But we still keep on doing that.
Teachers all over the
planet are doing that.
30 kids, and they're
trying to say, well, no.
We're going to learn that
all together-- a nice day.
So what's next for us?
So we're experimenting with
these learning experiences.
We are working on new
game play or new games.
And there are many, many,
many things we can explore.
We are a very tiny team--
I don't know-- 13 people?
But we see many research areas.
For example, now in many
countries in South America,
they have a one to one
with the same tablets.
What can you do if in a whole
country each kid has a tablet?
What kind of interaction
can you make?
What kind of learning experience
can you generate there?
It's fascinating, the number
of facilities we have there.
I think we're going to
spend time exploring this.
How can we create a
game experience there
with this hardware?
Much more to do
with higher math.
There are many areas
of exploration.
AUDIENCE: Thank
you for the talk.
It was really excellent.
I have a question,
which is do you
feel that the game is
sufficient in itself
for learning to happen?
Or do you think it's
best used as a tool
in the hands of teachers
to map the concepts,
the mathematical concepts, to
other real world or whatnot?
JEAN BAPTISTE HUYNH:
So if you are parents,
I would play this
game with your kids.
I wouldn't let them
play, actually.
I would play it with them.
Just like you help
them learn to bike,
and you're very
glad when they bike,
I would play this game
[INAUDIBLE] for algebra,
and explain more how
to transfer that.
In the algebra game, it's
really about the manipulation,
the algebraic manipulation.
It's not enough.
We don't say why
it works like that.
So there is no link
today to arithmetic.
So it must be complemented by
either a teacher or a parent.
At the moment, it's like that.
AUDIENCE: You said you
were working on some things
to help with the transfer from
the game to pencil and paper.
Can you describe what those are?
JEAN BAPTISTE HUYNH: Yeah.
In the game, you
manipulate cards, right?
And there is a help mode.
We really help kids really
get fluidity in doing things.
So we are helping them a lot
in the interaction design.
But there is one step where
we don't help them at all.
So there is no help.
And then there is the
handwriting recognition.
So we can go towards
the full stuff there.
And just what I've
mentioned, not a new game,
but a kind of
experience where they
can link the algebraic rules
with what it means with numbers
so that they connect the two.
So that's very important.
Connect arithmetic and
algebra, and then you
have the full package.
Yeah, so it's possible to do it.
AUDIENCE: So first
of all, thank you.
I love these games.
My daughter does too.
One thing I noticed is
that my wife loved math
until she got to trigonometry
and then gave up on it.
And I got her playing the game,
and she couldn't put it down
until she stayed up till like
1:00 AM to finish the game.
JEAN BAPTISTE HUYNH: I'm sorry.
AUDIENCE: No, it's
a great thing.
And so I'm wondering if you guys
are looking at adult education.
I mean, that seems to be a
huge growing market as well.
And I totally
understand your point
too about how you
show this to adults,
and they say, oh,
this isn't math.
I don't know what this is.
Because algebra,
which she loves,
when I showed her that
one, she had that reaction.
But trigonometry
and geometry, which
she doesn't love or understand,
she could play it like a game.
So I'm wondering.
Are you guys thinking about
approaching the adult education
market and breaking
through those barriers
and things like that?
JEAN BAPTISTE HUYNH:
Yeah, definitely.
We're going to do that.
But when we designed
the game, actually,
the first game about algebra,
it was meant for kids around 12.
And because of the constraints
we had made-- no language,
and it must be like a
game, and unfortunately
or fortunately, I don't
know, one of the "Wired"
Geek Dad journalists wrote an
article saying it's incredible!
My five and seven year old
girls are playing algebra.
And since then who
are our customers?
What do you think?
Parents with a head
start in their head
and they're thinking
yes, algebra for my kids.
My point is that we're
going to target higher math,
but always with the
same constraints.
And in math, the
beauty is that it
can be very visual if
you have the right design
of the interface.
But definitely
statistics, functions,
calculus, or
trigonometry can be made.
I mean, I'm pretty
confident we can do that.
But we have limited resources.
So maybe there are other
people who can do that too.
I promised my son to be finished
with the high school curriculum
before he leaves
school, and it will not
happen unless other people
are joining in the mission.
So I encourage you to do that.
Yeah.
[APPLAUSE]